is moon knight just another street level
vigilante in the marvel universe just
another superhero no not at all
wondering how his multiple personality
disorder and literal god-given powers
give him an advantage keep watching
mark spector crossed paths with konchu
in his adult life after a botched
operation left him near dead in an
african desert barely making it to a
mystical egyptian tomb spectre passes
away at the feet of the moon god statue
leading to his spirit meaning konchu the
ancient deity saved spectre's life in
exchange for the mercenary becoming his
knight as specter himself recounts in
moon knight volume 9 number 1. this
encounter gives birth to the superhero
called moon knight and fundamentally
changes not only spectre's life but his
brain as well due to the nature of
konchu's powers as a multifaceted
extra-dimensional entity his
interactions with spectre are said to
have contributed to the fracturing of
spectre's psyche in fact it has been
explained on more than one occasion that
spectre's dissociative identity disorder
may have been a direct result of his
mind attempting to match the complex
nature of the god's own persona
furthermore spectre sometimes possesses
the ability to switch between his
personas at will including moon knight
himself which is actually a separate
personality not just a secret identity
the already formidable traits that
spectre possesses due to his military
background are amplified by the powers
of whichever persona is in charge at the
moment
for a time moon knight was able to
harness konchu's powers in the form of
superhuman strength according to the
official handbook of the marvel universe
marvel knights 2005 the fist of kanchu's
physical strength increases under the
light of the moon peaking during nights
with a full moon interestingly moon
knight's strength speed and agility are
all affected by the phase of the moon
full moon half moon waning or waxing
crescent or new moon these fluctuating
power levels are said to be in place
because of specters direct ties to both
the moon and the egyptian god other
guides such as the official handbook of
the marvel universe deluxe edition
number nine established that spectre is
typically capable of bench pressing 450
pounds however he can lift approximately
4 000 pounds when he's operating under a
full moon in recent years however moon
knight has had to deal with the loss of
this useful ability forcing him to push
himself to his physical limits in order
to continue his superhero activities as
spectre himself explained in moon knight
volume 5 9 his super strength was
stripped away from him by a wrathful
kanchu after he went against the gods
orders
as moon knight can likely attest the
cool thing about having a god on your
side is that for as long as they have a
reason to keep you around death will be
less of a final destination for you and
more of a revolving door not that death
ever tends to be permanent in the marvel
universe but still in the case of moon
knight this means that unless konshu
decides to find a new servant spectre is
functionally immortal
in a discussion with his psychiatrist dr
andrea sturman in moon knight volume 9
number 1 spectre confronts the
uncomfortable question of whether or not
he can die with a level of uncertainty
he even recounts that kanchu has
resurrected him not once not twice but
at least three times including when they
met in the egyptian tomb hence on more
than one occasion moon knight has found
himself in a situation where he should
have died but didn't that said konchu
doesn't seem to have any qualms about
reminding spectre that he is disposable
in moon knight volume 5 number 6 during
a vision in which he took the form of
moon knight's horribly disfigured
nemesis bushman he took spectre's life
and brought him back just to prove a
point
while moon knight may be functionally
immortal that doesn't mean his body is
impervious to injury like luke cage in
fact moon knight's battles tend to be
extremely brutal bloody and violent they
almost always end with both him and his
opponents sustaining broken bones
smashed limbs massive bleeding and other
types of physical trauma
rather impressively spectre is able to
bear the extreme pain that comes from
his injuries he has a near superhuman
level of endurance even in the base of
torture from his most sadistic enemies
moon knight's high pain tolerance has
been said to be a combination of his
mental state khanshu's empowerment and
the sheer amount of physical abuse he
experienced during his time in the
military this has led to specter
enduring pain unlike that of any other
street level superhero for instance in
moon knight volume 5 number 6 spectre is
shown to be basically unaffected by
direct crossbow shots from taskmaster
and is able to soundly beat his foe
despite the severity of his injuries six
issues later his crazed former partner
midnight subjects spectre to an inhuman
level of torture his limbs are pinned
against the giant clock that digs into
his back to systematically remove
spectre's vertebrae one bone at a time
moon knight endures his pain long enough
to break free from his restraints he
then defeats his enemy by ripping off
one of the clock's hands and stabbing
him fatally
avengers vol 8 number 33 depicts moon
knight during one of his most powerful
phases in an attempt to stop the
machinations of the hellish ruler
mephisto khanshu decides that it's time
for his earthly avatar to bring about
the age of konchu he imbues spectre with
a host of abilities that the superhero
has never possessed before a fraction of
what konchu himself can do among the
powers that spectre temporarily receives
from the moon god is the ability to
literally control moons and anything
that was made from moon-based materials
this came with the implication that moon
knight could also control many other
celestial bodies as they are mostly made
up of materials of similar cosmic origin
while this power on its own is already
impressive it also granted spectre a
frightening new ability he could
manipulate one of the marvel universe's
most iconic and fearsome weapons a tool
wielded by another god thor's hammer
mjolnir is made out of uru a metal ore
reportedly as old as the universe itself
since urum metal is formed in a dying
star's heart from material that comes
from a primordial moon moon knight's
newfound lunakinesis allows him to
control thor's weapon regardless of his
worthiness spectre demonstrates this
when he makes quick work of the thunder
god by smacking him around with his own
hammer
mark spector shares his mind space with
at least four other main personalities
each with their own unique skill sets
and talents reflective of conscious
multiple aspects combined with his main
persona's own fighting skills and
deductive reasoning spectre maximizes
the talents that each of his personas
brings to the table there is of course
the moon knight persona which is said to
represent kanshu's side as the watcher
of overnight travelers as shown in moon
knight volume 9 number 1. then there's
mr knight a suave sharp dressed
consultant who typically does the
talking there are also two alter egos
that spectre psyche developed in his
youth stephen grant and jake lockley
brant is depicted as a wealthy public
figure and is the persona that finances
moon knight's activities he utilizes and
grows spectre's wealth to allow him to
operate as a costumed vigilante likely
on the other hand is a taxi driver who
wanders around new york and gathers
intel from street level sources for a
brief time in his career spectre was
also able to tap into the abilities of
three iconic avengers sort of as shown
in moon knight volume six number one
spectre developed the personas of
captain america spider-man and wolverine
and would even occasionally have
meetings with them whenever each of the
personas takes control spectre even
equips himself with the appropriate gear
to mimic their iconic movesets
yet another example of a short-lived but
spectacular power in moon knight's
arsenal was shown in avengers volume 8
number 33. after being allowed to tap
into the vast reserves of konchu's might
moon knight gained the ability to absorb
the powers of his opponents via mystical
artifacts however his impressive
absorption abilities also had their
limits moonite first put this ability to
the test in a confrontation with the
iron fist danny rand after subduing iron
fist with a barrage of conscious powered
attacks spectre whips out a divine ankh
which he uses to steal the power of the
immortal dragon residing within rand
using the anks and a bit of necromancy
moon knight easily defeats doctor
strange as well and brazenly takes
control of ghost rider robbie reyes as
spirit of vengeance however the onks
were a virtually no help to moon knight
when he went up against wakanda's
t'challa revealing their limitations as
black panther's powers were granted by
the heart-shaped urby consumed moon
knight could not use the anks to steal
them
[Music]
while moon knight has sported quite a
few different looks over the course of
his costumed career his most iconic
ensemble remains his all-white hooded
suit
and while they may not look like they
offer much in the way of protection
spectre's assorted outfits are actually
designed to be as resistant and durable
as their wearer they're also all white
of course as moon knight prioritizes
shock value and intimidation over the
element of surprise when it comes to
subduing perps spectre's early suits
include kevlar vests as well as a host
of defensive and offensive features
later on moon knight would tweak his
getup to offer even more protection
infusing the design with carbonadium in
the marvel universe carbonadium is
described as a flexible material
comparable to adamantium in terms of
quality and durability you may know
adamantium is the material that coats
wolverine's bones and carbonadium from
its heavy use in x-men villain
omega-red's tentacles moon knight also
wears a long cape that enables him to
catch up drafts and glide across limited
distances as well as metal bracers on
his arms some of moon knight's most
recognizable weapons include his
crescent moon shaped throwing blades and
his adamantium laced bow staff
incredibly the one thing about moon
knight that many may perceive as a
disadvantage has proven to be the
superhero's strongest line of defense
against some of the marvel universe's
greatest minds due to spectre's mental
state the white clad crime fighter has
developed a powerful resistance against
various forms of psychic attacks and
attempts at mind control his mental
resilience also makes it tremendously
difficult for telepathic individuals to
read his mind effectively deterring them
from anticipating his next move or
discerning what his true objectives are
moon knight doesn't take too kindly to
mental invaders in fact as moon knight
volume 9 number 2 shows his mind can be
a very hostile place for unwelcome
visitors while facing off against a
criminal telepath named holly moon
knight was able to overpower his
adversary almost as soon as he invaded
specter himself claims that his direct
interactions with konchu have turned his
mind into poisoned ground the villain
was thoroughly overwhelmed by moon
knight's sheer mental fortitude and was
rendered catatonic after their encounter
while he generally doesn't have access
to this ability moon knight was once
able to wield complete control over his
physical form this includes the ability
to pass right through otherwise
impassable objects as well as being able
to survive in places without an
earth-like atmosphere for extended
periods of time in conan serpent war
number four moon knight finds himself
temporarily time displaced upon his
return to the present day spectre
discovers that he is able to pass
through the glass pane of his residence
transforming into his costumed altar
upon stepping out this power boost which
was granted by khanshu to enable his
servant to complete a series of
complicated tasks is also seen on full
display in avengers volume 8 number 33
as moon knight himself observes he's
able to ride ghost rider's flaming 1969
dodge charger and even battle thor in
outer space without dying
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]